is it really worth it to go all in on
the social media thing so like go all in
on YouTube go all in on on all the
platforms yes let me just commit yes let
me tell you why it is grossly
underpriced attention
and it gives you the leverage yeah and I
saw that we had that meeting in the car
and I like literally watched you go do
the right thing by YouTube Instagram
making the memes like I'm watching I'm
like he's [ __ ] doing it what has
happened extreme growth what about
outside of the followers and things that
like what about in real life like I mean
extreme growth colleagues people that I
was cool with now you know stepping in
and wanting to do more because they're
seeing more of it and then they're just
seeing the the audience grow
authentically yes all in every [ __ ]
person listening to this and if you're
listening to me you're already in the
consideration set of debating should I
roll it if you're even listening to this
right now the answer is yes because if I
22 months ago needed to remind my own
self I need to go all in Everybody Needs
reminding